détective, il y a une situation qui
exige le meilleur des meilleurs, nous ne portons pas de
manoirs en briques et nous savons qui
Tremaine Alexander nous avons besoin de vous pour
infiltrer localiser l'appareil en
désarmant j'ai passé toute ma carrière à
essayer de m'abattre ne quitte jamais
les manoirs en briques et  il y a des points de contrôle
partout hypno Intel A l'intérieur pas de femme nous
avions tes yeux lino Dupree
xpath des Caraïbes françaises c'est si tu coopères
il restera a sa petite amie parler
de cette bombe tu frappes l'acheter les
choses doivent te rendre un peu
anxieux en prenant mon Aleksandr non
je fais de
l'anxiété